good health now sponsored by partners in
primary care
2021 is around the corner and partners
in primary care wants to help us to
remind you to keep health goals
in mind as we make our resolutions right
here's
here's more information welcome back dr
addis
hi thank you thank you for having me
good to see you again as always now
introduce us quickly to you and partners
in primary care
okay i'm dr laura adams on board
certified in internal medicine and i've
been here in las vegas for 18 years
and i'm with partners in primary care
we're a senior focused
primary care group that has six offices
right here now
in vegas spring valley southeastern
fremont street north rainbow south
rainbow
and we'll be opening another two clinics
in west craig and henderson coming up in
early 2021
that's great you cover the entire valley
for our seniors and with the new year
approaching
do you suggest seniors have health goals
in their new year's resolutions
absolutely what we're recommending is
starting a new year's resolutions early
and planning your annual physical with
your health care provider for next year
by doing so you can get a jump start on
your health
and we can also look at preventative
things to help
keep you healthy and happy and find
things that can do to improve your
lifestyle
so it's a great time to do this and it's
a great time for you to get to talk to
your doctor about your health history
any concerns that you might have be it
social or
psychological or what have you and make
some lifestyle changes and do some
healthy screenings
good advice and why is this important
for people who are relatively healthy or
feel like they don't
need to see a doctor well the purpose of
the first visit when you do a wellness
visit with a doctor is
to so for the doctor to get a handle on
what your health status is now and yes
if you're healthy that's great
we want to keep you that way we don't
only want to see people when they're
sick
we like see our people when they're
healthy so we can plan and do screenings
to keep you staying focused
and on the right track for your health
and what if you're looking for a new
doctor
you don't have a primary physician yet
well
a lot of people start by asking their
friends and families and that's always a
good start
um also make sure the doctor that you
pick accepts your insurance
you know a lot of the doctors now are
only being specific
certain insurances at partners in
primary care
we accept a range of medicare advantage
plans
so we have options for patients
and also if you're able to
you can come and do a tour of our clinic
and i also recommend looking up reviews
if you look up reviews you'll see a lot
about your doctors and learn a lot about
them
and in this day of information we can
find out so much
it's really a great opportunity though
to start your research now so you can
get healthy for the new year
i agree and i have taken a tour of one
of your facilities and they're very nice
state-of-the-art
they really are they we did a very nice
job we have special parking
you can park right out in front walk
right in
offices are big and clean and brand new
it's a wonderful place
and our care dedicated care team is here
to help
patients with all of their needs be it
physical
social behavior whatever it is that you
need we're here
to get in touch with partners in primary
care call 702 623
just visit seniorfocuslasvegas.com
kindle